hello everyone it feels weird coming
back from the having a day off yesterday
like I'm trying to get back in the swing
of things
did everybody I hope Steve held it down
okay from what I saw he did so Bravo
Steve we have a full house
mr. Pakman has brought out everyone here
in the show as always Casey here on
Tuesdays with ideology hello Casey hi
how you doing I'm doing fantastic the
sharp gentleman on the far end Jamie
welcome back sir yes thank you for
having me I'm glad to see everybody and
the we are sir and the star of the show
tonight
also the fine-looking gentleman in the
center mr. David Pakman welcome sir
thank you for coming on thanks for
having me
absolutely so tonight yes Casey did you
forget Steve oh you started with Steve
if I did know it was the second show we
ever did actually and I getting used to
the life you know the live streaming it
takes a lot because it's not like
recording we recorded the first couple
episodes that we did and you're able to
go back and you know fill in and fix
whatever you mess up so I'm scrambling
to try to focus on you know what I'm
gonna open up with and I open the show
and I said hello everyone I'm Kyle
Curtis and I've joined by this other guy
and I'm waiting on Steve to break in I'm
waiting oh seem to break in to save me
like obviously I'm dangling here on a
limb and he just sits there like he'll
get it eventually
so tonight we're going to talk about the
death penalty and should be abolished
this is a kind of a I guess roundtable
discussion where I'd like to get
everybody's thoughts I know that they
vary
quite differently between everybody in
this call so I think this is gonna be a
really good kind of back and forth and
getting everybody's ideas out there from
the polls that I put out on Twitter and
YouTube and discord it's widely varied
and a lot more split than I thought it
would be I thought it would be a clear
indicator towards you know being
abolished that was just my prejudice
going in I guess but it turns out it's
it's not that simple
and we're gonna get into that a little
bit later as well but right now I'm
going to allow mr. Patman to say a few
words and let you guys know where you
can find his show it's also in the
description but I want to kind of David
I'm sure everybody watching those who
you are but just for formality sake we
kind of let people know who you are what
you do and why you do what you do yeah
sure I host a progressive talk show it's
on close to 200 radio and TV stations
it's the 11:00 p.m.
weekday Eastern Time show on free speech
TV which is on DirecTV and Dish Network
and then we've got a YouTube channel as
well which now we surpassed about
500,000 subscribers I think we must be
around 525 at this point right now we've
got a podcast and I've been doing it for
four years it's my full-time job it's a
show that has you know a number number
of full-time staffers and that's that's
what I do about five days a week
busy man so we definitely appreciate you
taking the time to come on in and chat
with us a bit and I chose this topic
because I just noticed from watching
your show it's something that you would
come back to on occasion it seemed to be
kind of a I don't know this this is just
my assumption but it seems to be like
maybe a personal thing with you or
something that you're really passionate
about so I thought this might be a good
kind of benchmark start out with is that
the case I mean is the death personal
it's no more personal than than any
other political issue I guess that I
have an opinion about okay cool
so let's do this then let's go down the
the line here and so that everybody is
clear on where we're coming from in this
call and then we'll kind of jump into it
you guys kind of say what your stance is
on it briefly we'll go into it a little
bit deeper just but just so everybody
kind of gets an idea of where you're
coming from we'll start with you KC
where where do you stand on the death
penalty being abolished I think it
should be abolished I'm against the
death penalty okay Steve I don't think
we should abolish it I think it needs to
be fixed but I don't think it should be
abolished okay Jamie yeah as far as our
current justice system exists today I
would absolutely abolish it but if there
was significant reform I would be for it
being implemented in a specific way
interesting that that's that's what I
kind of want to start off with but David
what is your stance on the death penalty
I'm against it and I think we should
abolish it all right so we're kind of
kind of split with Jamie being a kind of
in-between guy there so Jamie let's
let's start at that middle ground then
when you say if it's if it can be
reformed then you would be for keeping
yet what do you mean by that first I
want to say I do everything I can to
avoid being sandwiched between you and
Steve and Here I am again in this exact
same time blending so my whole thing is
you know the short short version of this
is I'm really sick and tired of the
United States giving people exceedingly
long prison sentences for really minor
crimes in comparison to the amount of
time they have to spend in prison so for
example you know Kyle you actually
covered this I want to add homies
episodes where a guy stole fajitas and
ended up with 50 years in a federal
prison so my general idea here and again
I can go into depth later but my general
idea is cap all prison sentences to ten
years and if it seriously needs more
than ten years make the death penalty an
option
primarily for for the purposes of saving
on feeding and housing and clothing a
criminal that has no no intention of
rehabilitating but I think that should
come significantly with a proper
understanding of that being the case
psychiatric you know for through
psychiatric evaluation and again a true
justice system not using the standard we
have set today I make that very clear if
we're gonna do things the way we're
doing them now there's no way we would
be capable of insuring somebody's
innocence or guilt we just do a horrible
job of that so yeah I take that approach
that I would trade having the death
sentence for knowing that no prison
sentence would be more than 10 years let
these people get back on with their
lives and weary incorporated into
society interesting I David you seem to
get a little rod up there that's one of
the most nonsensical points of view I've
maybe ever heard on this issue and I've
done a lot of debates about this is it
okay if I ask a couple questions to try
to figure out a little bit more about
what you mean sure so Jamie the forcible
rape of a child would that be in the
under 10 years or in the death penalty
side well I'm not the person who's
qualified to make that determination
what I'm saying is is if it's determined
that it deserves more than ten years by
people who are qualified then it would
be a death sentence so if I understand
correctly you're saying like the current
way it's set up is you're not okay with
you cannot you cannot do it that's why I
say it would need massive amounts of
reform what I'm saying is if somebody
says you're gonna get three consecutive
you know life sentences or you know
three you know that kind of stuff it's
like what are we doing here I mean
there's there's no okay I got you
understand but here's what I'm trying to
figure so you've made it clear that the
current system is set up by the people
who are in charge is not okay but then
when I asked you for your view on a
specific case you said that's for the
people who set it up to decide but you
said that those are the people that are
doing it wrong right so if you if you
have know if you're not going to give an
example of like that
that you can give us a sort of your view
on if you want to okay who are in charge
the review but you're against how
they've done it now so why would you
think that they would do it the right
way next time because I would implement
more there would be more involved in the
process than we have right now that's
why I said like right now there is no
psychiatric evaluation done to determine
the the success or failure of possible
rehabilitation it's done through the
prison system it's not done what do you
what do you mean so in so but the prison
system doesn't determine the sentence so
you want psychiatric evaluation right in
the prison system
it's the justice system that determines
the sentence when someone is found
guilty so why would the prison system
having psychiatrists have any bearing on
the penalty that's assigned at verdict
you didn't hear what I said
the psychiatrist would be during this
you know during the pre-sentencing
really part of the justice system they
have that already that it's false to say
that that doesn't exist now it's used as
part of sentence in countless cases not
in terms of potential for rehabilitation
no absolutely that's a question that's
asked all the time there of
psychiatrists at sentencing okay well
I've never seen it myself okay I mean
this is this actually your hostility
here is a little little high for this
topic it's just like it's such a and I
it requires a significant amount of
maturity to talk about the issues openly
I mean I I'm not I'm not at all
advocating this on a political platform
not running for office on this position
I'm just discussing it in the set one of
the things we have that's a major
problem in our country is significantly
long prison sentences that are unfair
and burdensome and we also have a issuer
we do we have to provide for these long
sentences so what I'm saying is and then
you also get to the deterrence factor
you know you know I haven't seen that's
been completely squash that's having a
death penalty does not provide any
deterrence benefit whatsoever I'm not
saying it's the significant amount just
saying that as it isn't a clear-cut yes
or no case so I'm just saying if we
lived in a society clear-cut it
you think I will share your view I'd
love to hear it yes what's your son
what's your solution David my solution
is we abolish the death penalty
okay just like sorry and have just like
um however long they're sentenced for or
life sentences but note just basically
the system we have now just no death
penalty well no they're definitely I
mean I agree that we have way too long
prison sentences for some crimes like
absolutely for sure the war on drugs is
a disaster that's a hundred percent but
I see that as totally separate from the
death penalty so I feel like the
whatever point of view one has
politically there is a good reason that
should appeal to that point of view to
get rid of the death penalty so like one
of the things that was mentioned was the
cost right the cost of keeping people in
prison for life that's actually cheaper
than the death penalty because since we
get it wrong on the death penalty
unfortunately too often people get
appeals right and that's just something
that our justice system affords even if
you've not been sentenced to death you
still have the opportunity of appeal few
people want to eliminate that as
something that is part of our justice
system as a result of those appeals and
the backlog of death row inmates and
states that have the death penalty and
the lack of availability of the drugs
that will work in a what's called not
cruel and and not inhumane way it costs
more actually for the death penalty than
to just say we're putting someone in
prison without the possibility of parole
particularly because those parole
hearings also incur a cost so like if
your big thing is cost you should get
rid of the death penalty if your big
thing is for some crimes that are so
heinous we want the the worst possible
punishment for someone putting someone
to death and just turning out the lights
doesn't even really seem like the worst
punishment the worst punishment to me
seems the rest of your life all you see
is the inside of that prison cell so
like if your priority is and this it's
not
but if someone had the priority of I
want the worst possible punishment it's
not just ending it it's making someone
live with the reality that they
committed a terrible crime and now
they've got to sit and rot in a cell for
the rest of their lives so these are
just a couple examples I won't go on but
but my point is whatever your political
beliefs are if you have a more
libertarian point of view where you
think that the government should have as
little power as possible because you
don't think the government is good at
doing stuff well then that includes you
don't think the government is good at
figuring out who's innocent and guilty
and you don't want to give the
government the ultimate power of ending
people's lives so I think that's the
sort of main point whatever politics
appeal to any individual there are
really good reasons to be against the
death penalty and to speak to your point
I did I've got I put together a list of
some some facts going towards why it
makes sense to abolish the the death
penalty and one of those things that you
kind of spoke to will take California
for example is it they have the largest
death row in the country and they've
spent over 4 billion on the death
penalty since 1978 while carrying out
only 13 executions so in the in you know
that length of time they've spent 4
billion dollars on executing 13
individuals and that that to me that was
the one of the things that they struck
out to me first hand we're gonna get
into the the the cost of maybe making a
mistake and you know putting someone to
death it's innocent I've got those
statistics on too but let's start out
with with the cost thing Steve you you
came out at the beginning and said that
you wouldn't want to abolish it what's
your mind frame for that what's your
mindset yeah there's a couple there's a
couple points to be brought up one when
you're talking about the cost the most
cost her because of appeal process and
if this goes back to what Jamie's saying
of how we need every man three vamp the
whole system the system is flawed and
Dave I think make some wonderful points
when it comes to do we give the
empowerment to a specific group people
to make these decisions and from a focal
framework we can make those decisions
all the time we always have people that
make those decisions for us
doctors make the decisions of life and
death all the time so if there was a way
that Jemmy is saying by which we can
have some kind of accountability here
for what would be something that would
be determined to be death the death
penalty I'm okay with that but I think
the question that people are missing is
what form of Justice are we trying to
achieve here you have read you'd have
retributive justice you have restorative
justice distributive distributive
justice procedural justice what is the
goal that we're trying to get out of the
death penalty and I think that before we
even try to answer the questions if she
should abolish it or not as which one
are we looking at because I don't agree
for retribution we should have the death
penalty I know David had talked about
this on a video that he'd says that we
should not have the death penalty as
some type of retribution I agree I don't
think it's a very effective means for
retribution
but what about some of the other means
by which we would say this would be an
appropriate type of situation for the
fairness of society that given that most
of us are not committing these heinous
crimes this person did maybe under more
procedural type of justice or I hate to
say restorative because nothing's better
you can't bring back the life of a
person right we can say if I stole from
jammy restrictive lies sort of ways I
could be told I have to be more fun well
I don't know I'd see which retribution
or retributive justice is punitive and I
don't think that's a very effective
means by which we can address the topic
of the death penalty odd but I think
Jimmy has a point it just requires a lot
more sussing out than I think what kick
here to get into in a you know to our
hang out like this right yeah and if I
can before I like yeah I'm just gonna
clarify I don't my point
I don't ever think that it definitely
should be used for the purposes of an
ultimate you know retribution or
punishment in and I do well that's the
part of that 10-year prison thing is if
there's your ten years for appeal now I
get that my ten years is very just
thrown out there and put a dart on the
wall but it's just to get the
conversation going
well yeah thank you Steve for
recognizing that it needs to be
thoroughly thrush doubt not not not
simple
and I'm only David responded but before
I do Steve what is your view as someone
that doesn't think that we should watch
it completely what it what do you think
the the best course of Justice should be
in you know right we should be very
limited well should be very limited in
scope I think that it's showing be for
the worst heinous crimes but it should
be for the protection of society if I
know that Jamie is a sillier serial
killer and he's been executed there's
zero probability of him ever going out
and killing another person that's an
effective means by which to protect in
society that's the only reason why I
would say we would need the death
penalty because people have gone to jail
and they still commit murder
they still do crimes right I mean even
in the jail system so if you want to
protect society from somebody who does
not have these things like compassion or
empathy or even where we will consider
because a soul per se which I don't
believe in but we think that a like a
sociopath we'd say they don't they're
soulless right they don't care they have
no empathy toward anybody if that is a
person that exists then I have no
problem by saying we as a society can
end their life if it's beneficial to the
rest of the society ok David who gets to
determine if it's beneficial to the rest
of society
the people we put in charge for that
same or if we do with doctors there have
to be very stringent rules by which we
have these types of decisions being made
it wouldn't be your average smoker deli
obviously there's somebody that'd be
well-rounded allergy I'm not sure I
understand the analogy to doctors
because you mentioned that a couple
times maybe we could explore that a
little bit I mean I think you know
number one criminals don't choose to put
the justice system in charge of deciding
whether they get the death penalty or
get life in prison for example people
are consenting to have doctors treat
them right so that's that's kind of like
part of the it's part of the way
medicine works I guess we can come up
with some like very specific situations
where someone is brought into an
emergency room and they're
non-responsive and the doctor is sort of
deciding that it's an emergency room
we're going to treat someone but for the
most part like the relationship of
someone to a doctor it doesn't have
anything to do with the relationship of
someone to the justice system that
determines whether they get life or life
in prison or the death penalty right so
I guess I'm not I don't I'm not sure the
relevance of bringing up doctors at all
sure these are ethical sure these are
ethical considerations right when a
doctor has to make a life-or-death
decision they have to take their account
the family's wishes they have to take
account the the chances they of the
patient recovering there's a lot of
factors that we give them the the
empowerment to do because they go
through school to be experts on this to
make those decisions and so every day
across the the planet doctors make these
life-or-death decisions I don't see why
it would be unfeasible to not have a
panel of some kind it could be you know
three five whatever but a panel to say
look at this crime has been so egregious
it is shocked at the consciousness of
the people so much I'm sorry but people
that go out and do school shootings
I have no compunction about ending their
lives as not just for retribution
because I don't think it's for
retribution is it to stop them from ever
doing something like that again and
Jamie is kind of right I mean the fact
that we don't have I don't think a
system where we evaluate people of the
propensity of their you know doing the
ever again in the actual trial I think
that's later on to more the appeal
process if I'm not mistaken right if
you're for a parole then it can be
evaluated are you still a threat to
society but do they through the actual
did you commit the crime I don't know
how much that is to take into account
but I think that people that are that
demonstrate they have no remorse no
regret and then might continue to have
these patterns of destruction then those
are the ones they need to focus on and I
can say we just allow a group of people
that are trained and those things to do
so and what if those people's no sorry
yeah no go ahead I was gonna say what if
those people determine that they believe
something else is worthy of being put to
death right I mean not say for you you
would agree that you know sounds like
serial murder terrorism maybe any
murderer I'm not sure you know you would
have your list right of like the the
crimes that would justify those people
assigning the death penalty but what if
they want to expand that and they've
been given that power what would stop
them from doing that well the same
reason is why we have the Supreme Court
right I mean there is an ultimate
authority when the Supreme Court says
this is the way it is it's a lot of land
they are empowered by the President to
make that decision right there the
president decides who's going to be on
the Supreme Court we don't vote them in
there is a check and balance system
though I think that maybe maybe
multi-tiered of some kind it might be a
local court that kind of puts it maybe
like a federal level or even state level
and then you co you have your appeal
process because I don't think we should
arbitrarily just say this person needs
to die and then go ahead and do it there
should be an appeal process there should
be a checks and balance system where we
know that this is the right thing that
we're doing but didn't didn't before
didn't you say that the cost argument is
only an argument because of the appeals
and if we cut down on that then the cost
argument wouldn't be a good one but now
you're using the appeals process to
defend giving people the ability to
decide who lives and who dies well
there'd be a huge difference in cost
between 20 years of Appeals and three
system where you have an appeal process
and maybe a year or two right you'd
start the site stay
go to the federal then you go maybe to
the highest court if needs be but we
have appeal after appeal after appeal
for decades on end these the criminals
are always having appeal processes so at
that point when you're asked in the line
as Texas said you know who was it that
said something on the lines of when it
comes to the death penalty they're not
trying to abolish it there put it make
an Express line for it
it skylit pointed out how many people
have actually been executed in the last
decade or 20 years in most states on
that our death row it's it's nearly
nominal compared to how many people have
gone to death row isn't it
it's a very small nobody here yeah
because that's not that's not really an
argument for or against the death
penalty right like the fact that it
takes a while to execute people that
doesn't really tell us whether it's the
right or wrong thing to do that's true
it's not it doesn't decide morally
whether it's right or wrong but it goes
to Jimmy's argument as we need it we
need to change the system and I could
not agree more
the reason the appeals take a long time
is because there's just so many cases I
don't think there's no way to expedite
it unless you know this is a serious
thing deciding to kill someone so the
idea of just like we just expedite
Appeals it's just not going to happen
because the court system is overloaded
and every case needs to be decided kind
of on its timeline and on its merits I
don't know how you just shorten the
Appeals time you know no I think it's
very fair point to make actually you
know you're exactly why it is it is
because there oh this course overbook
but again this goes back to what Jamie
said why are we why are we punishing
certain things that don't need to be
criminally punished in the first place I
am you said something that I totally
agree with the drug war was a ball
abominable from the get-go it was from
an its inception just flawed it is it
has been a nothing but a travesty would
you agree oh yeah absolutely
okay so I think everybody on here
probably agrees with that and just
biting that alone would probably
eliminate many of the problems but I do
agree that we should not have people
that have 30 years in jail what good is
that anymore what what what I'm telling
you as somebody in some cases and
probably say they were innocent 30 30
years yeah excluding the death valley
stuff but people just have gone to cry
you know done petty crimes I got a
decade or 20 years that
me is just nonsensical absolutely not
okay say you had a question you wanted
to get in real quickly yeah so my
question is if you have this list and
this is for anybody who wants to jump in
but as Steve made me think of it if you
have this list of crimes that are that
warrant the death penalty right it would
that be applied equally and objectively
because right now sentencing is not
applied objectively it's very subjective
and based on pretty much whatever the
judge wants to do that particular day so
it would it be like a stringent list
black and white this is what gets the
death penalty and this is what does it I
think the reason why you don't have
consensus across all the jurisdictions
is because they have this huge wide
spectrum of sentencing you know
everything from one year to life by
narrowing it down significantly I think
it would force that type of black and
white and in uniformity with with the
jurisdictions that's what that's why I
was saying is by capping it you really
force people to rethink are you know
you're gonna you're my point for capping
and I may be David this is where I I
I might have caused a misunderstanding
here my point for capping was not to say
yeah let's do a lot more you know
executions my point for capping was
hopefully to actually minimize the
number of executions but make it and a
better option that it is today it's a
it's not a good option at all in any way
shape or form that's why I'm not for it
at all right now
that's if them clarifies at all I don't
know if it does I mean it's just aren't
there's so many crimes that we would
probably all agree don't warrant the
death penalty but a 10 year sentence 30
percent of which could be removed for
good behavior for prison crowding like
neither one of those would be the right
sentence I wouldn't do I went to
reductions that's the point so you get a
30-year sentence and then they're out in
15 years it's like okay five years
shorter I mean is it really making a big
difference
five years is enough let me rephrase it
then
about the reduction yeah wouldn't we all
be able to identify crimes where the
death penalty is too much but ten years
on the nose is really not enough oh sure
yeah I'm sure yeah that's why I said I
mean I would just throw this out that I
can't I told Kyle before I came on to
the show that the idea was just to
discuss this just throw out some ideas
and kind of cover every corner case it
wasn't for me to come on and say David
you're wrong and I'm right and let me
prove it to you oh sorry I just say he
he just he was putting out like a
thought experiment for us to kind of
base off of yeah yeah no that's fine I
mean I think that you know the the for
me the fundamental thing there's always
a question when you talk about this
where my pullet my values are not the
same as everybody else's right like even
everybody else on the panel or anybody
else who has like a position on the
death penalty so oftentimes the
conversation around it becomes about
based on the values of the person you're
talking to does the death penalty make
sense or doesn't it make sense so that's
like where I said if your big thing is
cost then you should be against the
death penalty because it's more
expensive than for example life in
prison
that's not really my concern right like
for me if you said well there's this
thing that's more expensive but it's
hugely morally wrong
I wouldn't say or it's it's less
expensive rather but it's hugely morally
wrong I wouldn't say oh well we can save
money like for me that's not that's not
the top value for me and really the the
opposition to the death penalty comes in
sort of two categories one is that
fundamentally no justice system is
perfect so like very often we will hear
from people and even sort of like what
you're saying Jamie which is if the
system worked better then you would be
okay with or you would be more open to
the use of the death penalty and I think
that that's it's a thought experiment
but it's not that useful of one because
no system is ever perfect right like
most of the times airplanes don't crash
but no system is ever 100
perfect so we what why would we even say
in a system where planes never crashed
XYZ and the reality is that we have
innocent people on death row we know
that one out of 25 is one estimate which
is like 4 4 % we have mentally ill
people on death row who don't even based
on psychiatric analyses really even
understand the consequences of the
actions that led to them being on death
row you will have fundamentally we have
a jury system in the United States and
whether it's the best system or not we
can debate but it's not a perfect system
so given that we will never have a
perfect system like isn't that reason
alone cost aside deterrence factor aside
which we could talk about it wouldn't
that be reason alone to say you know
what we can undo life in prison no
matter what like we it's not an
irreversible decision people who are in
life in prison without parole don't go
on to kill other people it's not you
know it could happen but it doesn't this
is that good enough um well it's kind of
funny because when you were to given the
airline analogy I wanted a quote Rain
Man and say what about Qantas airlines
[Laughter]
the so ok so I kind of want to say two
things at the same time one was you you
brought up morality earlier and then you
also just mention innocent life so is my
question for you before I can answer you
is is morality to you the idea that an
innocent life is taken or just the fact
that we're killing people for any reason
whatsoever is the issue like what is the
moral moral issue about this with you
the the moral issue issue for me is
based on my view about what it is that
governments should and shouldn't do I
don't see any way to justify the
government saying here's a list of stuff
for which we kill you
okay so it's not about a cost thing
because if they lit because I don't
think it naturally follows that if we
would fix the cost thing it would change
your no directive on the day like I said
for like for me I think if you care
about cost it's cheaper to do life in
prison that's not my priority right so
like that was sort of a if I'm talking
to someone who says cost is the most
important thing I might mention that but
for me that's not really the issue but
that doesn't follow I could say the cost
is the most important thing I support
the death penalty but we need to fix the
cost we need to fix the system to make
it less expensive I've did they already
dropped mine dry okay well we're sorry
about that from the outside we'll
continue where we left off I was just
saying that it doesn't necessarily
follow that if your goal is to to reduce
cost that you have to be against
definitely the goal would then be list
fix the situation where we're not
spending so much but keep that lease
okay sure you could make that argument I
think that the ways you fix the cost
issue cause new problems like for
example you get rid of the appeals four
percent of the people on death row are
innocent so we I think we need the
appeals so I think that there's like a
there's a follow-up argument which is if
you want to fix the cost how do you
actually do it in a way that doesn't
cause new problems but like I said for
me like I don't start arguing against
the death penalty on the basis of cost
if that makes sense no I totally agree
with you and I and I think that the the
one of the biggest concerns I think
everybody probably has and when it comes
to the ethicacy of these things is what
happens with an innocent person that's
to be a primary consideration right
unfortunately people do get me go to
jail and they're innocent and so of
course that people going to execute an
innocent anything case he brought it up
it's not fairly distributed by any
stretch in that say gee when you get
there but here are the here are the the
facts surrounding that
number one false informant testimony is
the the top cause of wrongful
convictions in capital cases many people
I think would think it would be DNA but
only 20 of the 150 death row
exonerations have been due to DNA
evidence we can trust the he said she
said thing when someone persons
testimony against another and you're
playing to something so important to
someone's life like how do you go about
justifying that well let me ask you this
when where's these done because
obviously the times have changed right
and I don't think anything should be
based on eyewitness testimony where
somebody's life is at risk that's just
nonsense but I think that because we
have better news ready as of 2016 so
some we still have we still have
eyewitness testimony putting people on
death row oh yeah there's this thing
called the CSI effect where people
expect that many more cases will be sort
of resolved in this neat and tidy way
where they come up and they've got
they've got the DNA evidence that's it
it's it's sort of open-and-shut and and
the majority of people in in all crimes
are not being convicted on the basis of
DNA evidence and I think what you said
is really interesting which is if nobody
should be on death row on the basis of
eyewitness testimony
that's almost everybody yeah so
what do you say that Steve well I mean
again what happens what do you mean by
always if we have a camera if I if I
have a camera set up somewhere and it
literally shows me shooting Jimmy and I
don't like keep doing it Jimmy I don't
want you dead okay just talking about a
jailhouse snitch rolling over because
the police went to him and he said yeah
I saw yeah so street corner that day
house example is one but but most of the
eyewitness testimony is not people who
have a very obvious incentive to snitch
and you know even even people in jail
are not necessarily getting a deal if
they if they make a claim like that I
think it's important to just remember
most eyewitness testimony is just people
who are pulled into the investigation in
some way shape or form III would go on a
limit probably say DNA is much better to
exonerate to than it is to convict the
in cases of exoneration only 20 of the
153 death row exonerations have been due
to DNA evidence so no the well again
just because DNA evidence can create
circumstantial it can create
circumstances which can write down just
propose how it might have happened but
someone's DNA could be somewhere for
reasons unrelated to the crime and just
because their DNA isn't there isn't
necessarily exculpatory either yeah
Jamie no say like OJ Simpson Oh
literally had blooded the vehicle and he
said it was for a totally different
reason I knew that was gonna I knew at
some point I was gonna come up so I'm
not I'm not been playing bingo
yeah that's we're too late now a little
bit but that's a good point I mean it's
it's a it's a good point
look at the glove the I mean that should
tell you it
there's a statistic here that I wanted
to cover this was the but to me the
glowing one and it hit I think to to
what Steve was saying about the
expediting the appeals process and
making it quicker to execute someone
because seven people were exonerated
from death row in 2014 three in Ohio to
North Carolina and one in Louisiana
six of the seven people that were
exonerated happened thirty years after
the inmate was locked up so the scary
thing is if we had an expedited process
you would have seven people that were
executed wrongly and at seven too many
well not as well again though the way
they convicted thirty years ago might
not not be the same that they would be
doing it now I mean back then people
were convicted for a lot less evidence
and unfortunately back then if you were
a member of minority you were much more
likely to be convicted than if you were
not in fort and that's and I think tie
so hopefully society has been growing
since and have been changing and where
we don't have that institutionalized
type thing but unfortunately again like
Casey said it's not fair at the moment
and that's not really yes that people
used to be convicted with far less
evidence I mean D let's put DNA aside
for a second but as Kyle said DNA is not
actually that big of a factor at least
in these death row cases that we're
talking about what evidence I'm curious
what evidence is there that people used
to be convicted on far less evidence now
of course it has to be more anecdotal
than anything else in my opinion but I
think that because we didn't have a lot
of the methods we use to determine guilt
from a crime like you the CSI technique
so you mentioned we don't have we didn't
have a lot but a lot of CSI techniques
our DNA well other than my fiber
analysis is still a very big thing in
forensics right a soil analysis
bacterial analysis doesn't have to be
necessarily DNA there's a lot of things
where they say this person was at this
scene because of these markers or they
had fibers or something along the lines
of saying other even two skin cells
don't require a DNA analysis right so
you can still determine that but
that's been around for a long time and
cases don't don't usually hinge just on
that you know I mean I'm open to what
you're saying I'm just saying I've not
seen evidence that we're convicting
people with with more evidence
necessarily right now do you think the
greater question is though is it worth
the risk like isn't it a better fix to
just hold them in prison for an
indefinite amount of time whether it be
for life or you know until they're
exonerated rather than risking executing
at least one innocent person so let's
let's let's use my my idea that I had in
it and replace death penalty with life
set let's say I went 10 years for life
sentence what would you say to something
like that just so I can hash out you
know or get through the the problems
with this model you know he's not
another gradation okay well yeah like
there would be some crimes that you know
didn't warrants to me the issue with it
the biggest issue with it is there will
be some crimes that don't weren't either
you know like what would you do with the
in-betweens and I think you would you
would wind up getting into a kind of
like what we have now just judges that
are arbitrarily you know imposing since
it's another bad thing that we have is
the mandatory maximum I know that's a
whole other debate but you know all of
that that entire sector of the criminal
justice system needs to be just
overhauled but isn't it
here's the risk this is why I support 10
years I'm a 25 year old kid who goes out
and you know does you know I put hold up
a store with a gun and round excellently
goes off and I unintentionally hit
somebody in the leg or something and
they still survived but it was a bad
situation and and normally they'd say
that's a 30 year sentence so I get out
you know I'm 55 years old now I got to
start my life all over again as opposed
to getting out at 35 years years and
going that was the stupidest thing I
ever did give me a chance to get back in
and try it you know try over again
something like I didn't get 30 years for
that some out some places you do this is
important it's a first-time offender
accidental non-lethal shot to the leg
was it a guy who stole a million dollars
with the fajitas got fifty years that is
true I mean this is that's just my these
are these two separate oh yeah these are
the guy who literally stole out of a
food truck a million dollars worth of
fajitas and they said fifty person well
he didn't know what woody what he did
was he worked at it he worked well he
worked at a detention center fun so what
he did what he would do was he ordered
the the food for the detention center
and he would order from this company a
extra cases of these fajitas right so
then he would take those out to the
street or whatever and sell those well
he ordered a shipment of them and he
didn't show yeah I sick that day right
so they went back in their agent but
counted it up he had a million dollars
with the feed is the judge game in 50
years and I think what the ultimate the
ultimat Albany to see here out of this
picture is that the issue is with our
sentencing laws if we were to overhaul
those it I'm not sure I believe you know
first of all I think 50 years is crazy
for that but I you know I think it isn't
his age and his age it is a death
penalty it's it's a life saying he's
dying in prison is my point I'm not
defending the it's it's cartoonish to
say that it was for fajitas and it
sounds funny but you're talking about a
guy who was basically stealing taxpayer
money skimming hmm it's computer I mean
this is a it's it's it's not 50 years
for me I totally agree
but the point
sort of like a 10 years or life or 10
years and death or it's it's not I just
don't think it's adequate for the
complexity level of the world we live in
why right I'm saying Wow wait why do we
why do we need a prison sentence of any
kind of long magnitude for a
white-collar type crime I believe
prisons should be much more tailored for
the violent offender I mean I knew that
we were always I live in I think there
are white-collar things that there can
be much more going for restorative type
justice and I think that many of these
crimes that are committed don't require
incarceration for 50 years that person
that that stole the V heaters for all
that money is no different than somebody
stealing a candy bar when it comes to
the efficacy of stealing they're not
going to harm society to the point where
they kick they're not they're not taking
somebody's do I detect it disagree
they're trying to compare somebody
walking into a gas station and grabbing
a candy bar to the some of the stealing
taxpayer money well yeah and and the
system that he had to set up in order to
do that like he had to lie to people he
had to I mean he did steal you're right
he did steal but it was like a whole
freakin like operation it's not like
walking into a gas station and stealing
candy but what is what is the
restoration going on by putting him in
prison what are we trying to protect at
that point I mean you can't so really
not good general getting back the money
would be would be more important right
paying back and giving back some of the
money and if they wanted to say okay
this person needs to go into this
program where they're doing community
service for 20 years or something like
that put him in them almost like I had
say the military type thing but where
they're giving back and they're paying
back to the taxpayer that to me is far
more effective than putting in prison
for 50 years because there's not a
threat to society of any magnitude
against somebody that I rather your
earlier points murderer to your earlier
point though Steve you were talking
about these sentences make an example of
people I know that people won't be
stealing fajitas anymore if they were
and you know the funniest part is the
same thing when it comes to like the
death penalty as a as a you know a
deterrent we all know isn't very
effective however there are people that
want to kill a cop because knowing they
won't they will they will be you know on
the death row if they kill a cop in that
particular instance like many things
well yeah but in the states that have it
I think it does have an effect I think
there is the death penalty have fewer
cop homicides than states that don't
have the death if I'm going to kill
somebody you know if the person is a cop
I think that people will probably take
much more pause to make that decision
then if they imply the way what's up I
just could say I can answer that in in
in a national survey in 2016 by all of
the u.s. police chief's they had to rank
what they considered to be priorities in
terms of effective crime reduction the
death penalty was last in that ranking
of for crime region I know I said it's
not a very good print ever measure I'm
saying for that one type of crime cop
killing I think it might be more
effective than it not it's not it's not
so here's the way this works and I know
I know you guys go for two hours Kyle I
don't know if you remember but I had
about 45 minutes today so I'm sorry yeah
you're good here's the thing about
deterrence and this is really really
important the criminology data says that
assuming that it is a generally speaking
strict enough penalty the exact
potential penalty is not a very big
deterrent so like let me give an example
jaywalking if the penalty for jaywalking
is two dollars versus $100 there's very
little deterrent effect from having it
be $100 rather than two what does make a
really big difference in terms of
whether people will jaywalk or whether
they won't is how likely is it that
they'll get the penalty at all right so
if it's two bucks and the cops are
regularly giving people that penalty
that's a deterrent if it's a hundred
bucks and people are regularly getting
that penalty it's equally at
so what we find out when we look at the
data is that when you consider something
like cop killing because that's the
example if the options are if I kill a
cop
I might get life in prison or if I kill
a cop I might get the death penalty
the deterrent is how likely you are to
be caught which is why in countries with
high levels of corruption where gang
crime and killing and murder are less
likely to go to be punished at all you
see more of it in the United States both
the death penalty and life in prison are
strict enough and it's likely enough
that you will get arrested and caught
that the difference between one and the
other has zero deterrent effect yeah I
agree
enforcing of laws is important yeah yeah
I know I don't think he said anything I
would totally disagree with I think that
there's some to be said by the degree of
the degree of measure by which we're
gonna be punishing somebody whether it's
a small ticket or large ticket doesn't
have a significant factor on people's
decision to break the law I totally
agree with that yes but I think when you
made the point about it do we have a
perfect system and you said it's
irrelevant to talk about it what you're
describing is irrelevant as well because
no system enforces all of the laws
equally they pick no no it's the
likelihood right you're never exactly
right if it was there's a 1% chance
you'll get caught for murder versus a
70% chance like the 70 is enough right
that's what we're saying it doesn't you
know David you're getting I think up to
your your time I don't know how much
time you have left exactly yeah I've
sort of got to go the conversation has
been really really good but I sort of
allotted some certain amount of time and
I've got people waiting for me you did
absolutely and we appreciate you coming
on we'll let you wrap up any last
thoughts that you have and then we're
still gonna stay on everybody so we're
gonna continue this conversation but um
I do want to thank you David for coming
on and giving us your up one of you know
thanks for having me great to hear
everybody's views and I really
appreciate the interest in having me on
absolutely take care David that's the
local okay thanks guys yeah this was a
very good conversation David
I was ready for us to meet you he's
already gone